no
i
[Música]
más
y pronto
no
yo soy yo ni soy comunicador social yo
soy carito y soy administradora soy
ignacio y soy ingeniero de producción
soy diana y soy comunicadora social
soy oscar y soy locutor soy alexandra y
soy abogado yo soy daniel y soy músico
pero cuando tenemos estas bragas de
colores juntos en el escenario somos
unos somos como que un cúmulo de ideas
convertidas en el escenario para crear y
para aceptar en la improvisación es
aceptar y es sumar y es apoyar esas
ideas que tú tienes con tus compañeros
esa es la única manera para nosotros
poder conseguir genuinamente una
historia improvisada a veces esas ideas
son un poco locas un poco raras
pero igual tú tienes que apoyar esas
ideas
y la manera para confiar en tus
compañeros al principio tienes que
confiar en ti yo sé que esto parece una
charla autoayuda
pero realmente para improvisar tienes
que confiar en ti y luego confiar en tus
compañeros y ahí con esa misma valentía
y generosidad vas a encontrar la magia
de la improvisación hoy vamos a hacer
una improvisación para ustedes en este
sombrero tenemos algunos títulos que
ustedes escribieron y vamos a regalarle
una historia de cuento de hadas
para llamar a los actores vamos a decir
con ustedes los actores que se sientan
la energía
vamos a sacar el título del título
el título la insoportable verdad de un
miembro pequeño
ok
así este es el título del cuento de
hadas que vamos a ver
con el título la insoportable verdad de
un miembro pequeño en el género cuento
de hadas con ustedes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
madre no me gusta este traje
[Aplausos]
me la vas a tener que poner igual yo no
quiero ser rey madre tú eres un gran rey
viene yo aquí y ahora pensando a ver
cariño cómo vas a conseguir a alguien
cariño miras ojos tú te ves a mí te
proyectas en mi la verdad es que no soy
mucho más guapo que tu madre pero yo no
quiero ser rey además que soy demasiado
pequeño
mira yo me voy a ir al bosque el reino
no me necesita no te necesito y quien me
va a heredar
no lo seas un hechizo que se yo siempre
buscando la manera más fácil tu mamá la
bruja la reina la que lo soluciona todo
te voy a hacer un hechizo realmente te
quedas fuera al mar
este año
madre por favor ábreme la puerta esto no
parece un cuento de hadas para que
respetes yo me voy a hacer en mis
hechizos para tener mi belleza que
siempre es la particular alguien viene
aquí arriba
bueno no lo sé es un mi madre me dejó
pues esta tarde
3 3
bueno ahí va mi cabello no
eso infinito en realidad
[Música]
hasta el momento acabamos de ver un
breve instante en una historia de cuento
de hadas realmente lo que tenemos acá es
un grupo de improvisadores escuchando
activamente las ideas o propuestas que
tiene cada uno de los compañeros que a
nosotros nos gusta mucho llamarle a
estas ideas regalos porque la palabra
regalo viniendo de un compañero o de una
compañera es algo que valoramos
muchísimo y si estas personas están
esforzándose en este escenario para
hacerme un regalo y hacerme brillar en
el escenario entonces yo me comprometo
muchísimo con cada cosa que ellos me dan
para poder juntos descubrir algo a una
historia en este escenario si nosotros
pensáramos ideas individuales que no
tienen nada que ver o conexión con las
que cada uno está dando estaríamos
dejando de aceptarlas y por ende quizás
no estuviésemos sumándole a la historia
entonces no podríamos ver un príncipe
que va a ser rey a su madre encerrado en
un castillo quizás con un caballo y una
princesa que
en el rescate
pero si nosotros realmente queremos
aceptar y sumar a través de otro regalo
que nosotros le vamos a hacer a este
compañero para hacer también brillar su
propuesta pudiéramos ver quizás una
biblioteca muy antigua llena con
distintos libros de distintos tamaños
quizás un poco de polvo y aire que entra
por una ventana quizás entre estos
libros muy grandes podemos ver un libro
que destaca que es mágico y que es leído
por un hechicero con una barba muy larga
encogido tuerto quizás que está a punto
de contarnos la mejor historia de cuento
de hadas de nuestra vida
escucha acepta y suma para poder
encontrar juntos una historia en este
escenario ahora vamos a hacer una
historia también en el estilo de la
novela pero le vamos a meter una
dificultad que nosotros le llamamos
metiendo la frase entonces cada uno de
nosotros tiene unos papelitos unas
frases que ustedes llenaron que muchos
de ustedes llenaron antes de entrar a
este escenario nosotros las tenemos en
estos dispositivos tecnológicos llamados
bolsillos y cada una de esas frases las
vamos a ir diciendo en la escena que va
a suceder a continuación que sucede que
cada vez que le damos estos papelitos
que ustedes escribieron vamos a tener
que darle valor a ese obsequio que
ustedes nos dan y justificarlo en la
escena ok vamos a escoger entonces un
título para esta siguiente historia que
sera
y
nunca es tarde para comenzar perdiendo
que nunca es tarde para comenzar
perdiendo y decimos todos juntos como
ustedes
[Música]
madre
ya no puedo con la presión de ser parte
de esta familia es demasiado grande no
escriba bajo el imperio de la emoción es
lo mismo que te digo flavio todo el
tiempo estás el tiempo de diode perfecto
y exacto
todo el tiempo de dios es perfecto
adjudicándole a los demás
responsabilidades que no son tu madre la
empresa está en la quiebra la empresa
está en la quiebra la herencia de papá
se nos acaba mamá mamá mamá el flojo
trabaja doble
moody's
ama y recoge eso no creo que nos pase
nada estamos protegidos estamos
blindados estamos estamos protegidos mi
amor somos una familia muy elitesca dame
la que tú la tienes bebé
pero el amor madre el amor
dame la fe que tú la tienes ese abogado
no nos hará absolutamente nada mover
como que me llama bla bla eugenia de las
altas casas del dinero
y hacer nada cariño
cálmate esa tarde
raúl estoy cansada de que no te decidas
todavía cuando nos vamos a casar a es
más grande de lo que parece la herencia
no en general patricio así funciona
cariño no nos queda mucho tiempo es
decir necesito acabar con las compras
del mes y posiblemente no aplicarse es
peligroso arriesga teníamos cásate con
mi patricia yo me voy a casar contigo
pero hombre cobarde no tiene mujer
bonita
qué
yo soy cobarde y tampoco soy bonito tema
eres demasiado perdedor raúl
patrón si patrón citar a la puerta que
le traiga la traigo la carta que usted
me estaba pidiendo
y resuelta ayer que ciertamente la
investigación que hemos hecho no que
dale que lo que no viene en carros
después lo que te menciono no bien el
carro la empresa está quebrada no hemos
producido un carro efectivamente esa
señorita que usted ve ahí es su hermana
[Música]
por mucho que cuidar
y claro no me tengo que casar contigo
raúl será que raúl conseguirá a otra
persona para que bajara de peso será que
se silencia estoy mucho más
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno como vieron esta historia la
construimos con las ideas que ustedes
escribieron ese azar no siempre coincide
esa frase que escribieron no siempre
coincide las escenas que estamos
improvisando como se dieron cuenta pero
ese es el regalo de ese azar es el
regalo que nosotros les damos a ustedes
y si hay un momento de incertidumbre o
inesperado justamente nosotros lo
aprovechamos y lo utilizamos para ese
juego es como esa oportunidad de nuevas
de poder jugar con algo distinto en
cambio si uno se congela si uno cree que
es un error o que estamos equivocados
entonces ahí va todo cuesta abajo pero
en cambio el azar la incertidumbre si
uno la acepta y la juega entonces eso es
lo mejor que puede pasar en una
improvisación
hoy ustedes jugaron con nosotros con
estas frases cada una de estas frases es
un estímulo externo que nos modifica y
tenemos dos opciones para nosotros en
escena es un papelito es un papelito
cuando lo lees tienes la opción de
jugarlo o dejarlo pasar si lo dejas
pasar el juego termina eso no avanza no
va para ningún lado pero si algo hemos
aprendido sobre la adaptación a los
cambios que saber que no importa lo que
hagas el entorno siempre siempre te
modifica y lo que tú tienes que hacer en
este caso es aceptarlo sumarlo y seguir
jugando por eso ahora les vamos a
regalar una historia
les vamos a regalar una historia musical
que lleva por título
una experiencia en el guaire
con el título una experiencia en el
guaire género musical con ustedes
[Música]
hola
de nuevo aquí
te ayudas a buscar el oro que nos va a
sacar de aquí
juntos ya me vine para acá con está
técnica ya aquí
por el río
vamos a encontrar
[Música]
o quizás
demonios vamos a remar
[Música]
vamos a ver el baile
bueno
todos
en el baile
o no
[Música]
en él
[Aplausos]
no me va a salir
morillo
yo creo que vayan a dicha moto si no yo
me quedo aquí con tu alza
e
desde lo que hacen ustedes allá abajo
aquí chile isabel ríos en las lucecitas
tanto si no me voy a encaramar en el
muro momento
está peligroso que se mojen en esas
aguas contaminadas
en lo que salgan de tratar de
rescatarlos pero lo que salgan la llevan
preso virus o sirenas y de en amor
a que las aves
no hace
porque ha caído en el poder sí tenístico
de las sirenas de guardia
estoy mutando soy una sirena
y yo me quiero juntar a ustedes
[Música]
quiero ser sirena que creía que
estuviera segundo aquí habitan sirenas y
cualquiera
esto es peligroso
y sirenas se convertirán la fama
[Música]
en la siguiente
como unas sirenas sirenas como una
sirena
chilena
el oro
y por eso mandamos
[Música]
repetido
sirenas somos unas sirenas sirenas a
sirenas somos unas sirenas a sirenas
somos una serie
a
demasiados años están alucinando
cómo hago para sacarlos de allí amigos
se sienten bien estando allí
estar aquí abajo que haya arriba
entonces me moriré con ustedes y qué
pasa qué pasa si se nos va el agua
segura bien se muere la tira
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como pudieron ver somos
y tinta
en la pintura existe un principio que
dice que de haber variedad dentro de la
unidad y unidad en la variedad
nosotros somos pinturas vivientes
entonces imaginemos un mundo en donde
cada uno de ustedes tiene un color de
braga distinto y juntos creamos la mejor
historia haciendo de nuestras
diferencias la mejor fortaleza
soy diana
[Música]
soy nación soy yo soy de sangre
realista
[Aplausos]